meanwhile the debate is happening final
debate between trump and biden is
happening that is happening on thursday
night
well now new rules have been set
according to the new york times
president trump and
joseph biden will be muted during the
portions of thursday's final
presidential debate
an effort by the organizers to avoid the
unruly spectacle that played out at the
candidate's first meeting in cleveland
last month now here's the thing i don't
think that you should mute the mics
i actually don't think you should mute
the mics the reason is if you're a
democrat i'm confused why you'd want to
mute the mics
if you look at the polls what you see is
that trump's performance in the last
debate killed him
it was terrible for him he started
dumping in the polls immediately after
that before he even got coveted
by polling data so why exactly would you
want to mute the mics okay so fine
they're muting the mics
as in the first debate each candidate
will be allotted two minutes of speaking
time to initially answer the moderator's
questions
under a plan announced on monday the
opponent's mike will be turned off
during that period
and attempt to ensure an uninterrupted
response trump said he wasn't happy
about it
trump said i'll participate i just think
it's very unfair i'll participate but
it's very unfair they changed the topics
it's very unfair that again we have an
anchor who is totally biased
the commission acknowledged both
campaigns might be dissatisfied with the
new rules one might think they go too
far
one might think they don't go far enough
the thursday debate is the final
meeting of the of the candidates there
were supposed to be three debates the
second one
got cancelled because the debate
commission unilaterally suggested that
trump's covet forbade it even though
there was no medical information that
suggested
that this was the case meanwhile
bill stephen trump's campaign manager he
claimed that the nonpartisan commission
he called the biden debate commission
had promised that the national debate
would be about foreign policy and asked
for to discard the six subjects
announced last week by the moderator
kristen welker those topics are fighting
kovid american
families race in america climate change
national security and leadership
you can see why the uh the trump
administration would like to talk about
foreign policy which is
a big bright spot for them as opposed to
more conversation about racism and
is trying i mean is trump a white
supremacist and all this garbage again
again okay so biden's people are of
course very happy with the rule changes
so once again it'll be trump versus the
moderator
for sure now final note here
it turns out that when people actually
look at policy when they look when
people look at policy when they look
beyond the personalities of the
candidates
it turns out that democratic policies
are just not that popular polls show
this
polls show that democrats may be more
popular than republicans but that is a
personality question
that is based on social disapproval it
is not based on actual policy 56
of americans according to gallup say
they are better off now than they were
four years ago a plurality
support republican policies over
democratic policies this culminated
yesterday in 50 cent
the rapper slash actor television
producer tweeting out a graphic of the
top tax rates by state
this is according to i believe fox
business
uh the the it showed top tax rates by
states under the biden tax plan
california would have a top tax rate of
62.6 percent
new jersey would have a 60 top tax rate
new york state would have a 58
top tax rate new york city would have a
62 top tax rate as according to the tax
foundation
and that is because of an increase in
social security tax as well as an
increase in personal income tax for
people at the top tax bracket 50 cent
tweeted out
what the f vote for trump i'm out f new
york the knicks never win anyway
i don't care trump doesn't like black
people 62 are you out of effing mind
so first of all it's not true that trump
doesn't like black people but it turns
out that democratic policies are wildly
unpopular so here is the good news if
you're a republican and you're deeply
worried about the outcome of this
election as you should be
if joe biden is elected president and if
the democrats take the senate right now
pollsters suggest there's about a 75
shot that democrats take the senate
there's no doubt democrats will promptly
go too far pass a bunch of crappy policy
and there will be a reaction to it in
two years
which means that what our real fear
should be is them wrecking the system
and adding seats to the senate and
completely changing the constituency of
the supreme court institutional changes
that outlast the temporary if however
democrats push too far
on the bizarre thought that this is not
about trump they made the entire
election about trump
so if trump is ousted and then they say
well really it wasn't a referendum on
trump it was a referendum on how much
people love high taxes
they will go for it they will go for
broke and the reaction will be exactly
50 cent's reaction
and the pendulum will swing back the
other way did you know that every like
on this video creates one additional
leftist tier don't ask me why that's
called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity hit the like button